good morning Harold how are you BP long
time how you doing man don't okay
explain Clayton Kershaw's dominance last
night basically going with one pitch a
fastball well I was surprised I wasn't
big on him going I thought he really
needed a little more rest he proved a
lot of people wrong but you know he's
able to really navigate through lineups
with what's effective we saw it last
night with the fastball I thought he put
it in certain spots and you know forever
people have said you pitch off your
fastball you got a chance to be
successful and he had the breaking ball
in the back of their minds they never
saw it he just executed explain to me
his motion and why it can vary sometimes
and how tough that is for a hitter well
you know a lot of times we see it has a
taste of a Japanese pitchers yeah and
when they get here and they do that
hesitation and and you got to start your
motion all over I think the one thing
that Clayton kind of incorporates that
it's a balancing point for him but it's
a it's a freeze that the hesitation so
to explain it real simple as a hitter
when the pitcher gets ready to go back
and he gets into his motion you're
starting to go back to get your rhythm
and when a guy stops it throws you off
and Clayton has that little hesitation
and then he delivers and you almost have
to start your hands and movement later
and so if you haven't seen much he can
he control you for a while and I think
that was really why he's had such great
success guys have not adjusted to that
motion and then he can throw all kinds
of pitches off of which is really good
as well you was a former second baseman
I'm sure have been in on those
conversations at the mound but seventh
inning Kershaw I don't know if it was
one sided there with Dave Roberts but
how does the pitcher stay in the game if
he really wants to in convincing the
manager hey he asked him what are you
doing out here is my game look at this
point I'm Clayton Kershaw when he's gone
through what he's gone through to get
here at this point
it's his game plan is simple I I think
Dave probably just came out to ask him
how's he feeling or maybe how do you
want to go after this guy I don't even
think it was a conversation you're
coming out I don't think that was even
an issue well the guy I would ask is
always the catcher because i went to
catch her to be honest and he can he's
he's a little bit removed there i know
that there's the relationship there but
i want the catcher to echo either what
I'm saying or what the pitchers in but
it has to be a 22 21 here advantage some
way and that's where I would go I agree
I mean that's what most people do and as
tough for that catcher to be right there
honest in front of the pitcher but
sometimes he has to do it look only way
I can equate it to I wasn't a picture
but Dick Williams would run out there
after it be a bang bang play at second
on a tag right and I'm standing with the
umpire to base runner and he come out to
me go did you get it and I'd be like oh
man why you put me in the middle of it
because I know this guy is gonna be
behind the plate here in another day but
I may not play anymore so I'd always say
yeah I got him and then the umpire be
screaming at me after dick went back but
you know you're going to side with who
you think then authority if your Cub
fans would you be nervous they're
probably nervous I wouldn't be I just
think their team is loaded you know the
Dodgers really right now kind of get a
chance to reset that game for Clayton
last night save the series he loses it's
over because they're they're tired i did
that last series of the division series
the rainout really hurt them their
formula is the bullpen let's get to our
pin use our bullpen that's what they did
really for five months of the summer to
get to this point and so not having that
day off really hurt them so now they get
a chance to reset now it's giving them a
full day and they can go back have a day
off today and then regroup tomorrow and
you've allowed their rotation to kind of
get set back recharged again but I still
think the Cubs have the advantage but
they did let the Dodgers
in the series how nervous would you be
if you're toronto and and what do you
make of jose bautista's remarks that the
ALCS is rigged well I'll know about rig
but they complain about more pitches
than anybody in baseball anyway the
whole team they always do so I get it
and then what's the ball to missed I you
know I can see it I think everybody can
see that there's a lot of balls miss but
they're at the point that got a hit they
didn't hit and you know if they hit they
win I don't think there should be a big
panic I can see them winning today they
face Kluber who was dead on the next day
they faced Thomas sent in this in the
shadows and they got shut down I just
think when they get back in the dome
they'll swing the bats up there in
Toronto and and we'll have a different
series but quit crying go out and play
that's just plain simple yeah just to be
fair to Bautista he was saying that got
a look at the video and count how many
times the Indians pitchers have thrown
pitches over the heart of the plate
hadn't been many says that it the system
is against the Jays or something in this
year's no I can't buy it I tell you that
if I thought it was I don't see it that
way at all times don't talking to Harold
Reynolds major league baseball Network
Analyst as the series now shifts to
Toronto with the game three with the
Blue Jays also when you're looking at
how these you know Dave Roberts and how
he uses his bullpen how Terry Francona's
using his bullpen you know we're sort of
kind of blowing up the the routine that
we have the formula here of using your
closer or how long you use them or how
often you use your closer will other
managers follow suit with this well it's
a playoff formula I mean I don't have
problem with it right now you can't
sustain this over 162 games it's just
not possible to have this too many games
in the summer where you're down five and
before you know it yeah this is a
shutdown inning and so is the next in it
and so is the next
so you're going to use your guy in that
high leverage situation every other
inning there's just so many more runs
scored during the course of the season
in the postseason it's totally different
yeah you release the Kraken and you come
out and set them down and and it's
worked for both those guys right now and
and you know I think it's the right
formula and postseason baseball good to
talk to you Harold it's been fun so far
tonight Game three between the Indians
and Jays on TBS Harold part of MLB
network's MLB tonight which airs live
before and after every League
Championship Series and World Series
game Thank You HR alright buddy thanks
for having me all righty Harold rooms
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience